eu sempre escuto muito que eu tenho uma
personalidade muito forte e isso fez com
que eu quisesse procurar um pouco mais
sobre a marca pessoal e eu gosto muito
de mudar
eu acho que esse é meu foco e se é a
minha marca
como é que eu me identifiquei isso é o
primeiro e identifiquei mais pontos
fortes e tentei maximizar os acusados e
[Música]
isso é um processo um tanto é que muitas
vezes esses pontos
te ajudam a ter segurança e
autoconfiança e podem ser um instrumento
de que outras pessoas se inspirem ti
como construir uma marca pessoal de
valores fazem parte da minha
constituição que eu quero expressar o
que eu quero ser porque escolhi ser
assim a personalidade é ela é a base da
marca e o que é a personalidade é a
repetição de atitudes um padrão que se
constrói através de atos inatos e
adquiridos quais as minhas competências
quais os meus conhecimentos habilidades
quais as minhas atitudes
o que eu quero expressar como o
comportamento como é que eu acho
nessa construção da personagem da marca
pessoal é muito importante você saber
como o outro enxaqueca e como eu me vejo
e às vezes pode ser um gatinho
mas tu podes transformado léo
eu ainda não sei o que eu quero
expressar a peça feedback para as
pessoas que conhecem e vai estruturando
o que deseja realmente transmitir
componentes essenciais
a construção da marca consistência
autenticidade eu acho o fundamental
o poder de influência exatamente como
steve jobbs ali naquela outra imagem ea
visibilidade e isso é muito importante
porque quando você constrói uma marca é
muito difícil transformar as grandes
marcas por exemplo vai fazer um trabalho
muito forte quando tendem a mudar é o
seu carro-chefe talento vários marca
pessoal aí volta à questão da pesquisa e
de saber identificá o que construir seu
comportamento sua marca a sua marca é
você no mundo é muito importante a gente
ser nós mesmos desenvolver isso é um
processo longo que o essencial é
invisível aos olhos